[Music]
[Music]
suits is a stand now episode in the
seminal series love death and robots
that once pretty straightforward and the
surface actually has a lot to learn back
from it the episode is filled to the
brim with Easter eggs pop-culture
references and more so throughout this
video I thought I'd break down
everything that you need to know about
suits and its ending this is full
spoilers ahead so if you haven't seen
the episode then I highly recommend that
you turn off now without the way I'm
definition and welcome to the channel
where I explain it so you don't have to
suits follows a community of farmers
that are seemingly under attack from
aliens or extra dimensional beings that
on the surface have similarities to the
creatures from secret Wars the episode
opens on husband and wife Hank and Beth
who after being alerted to a breach in
their property line spring into action
to take down whatever threat may come
through it what I love about suits is
that it initially begins pretty
straightforward I imagine that a lot of
rural Americans will find this opening
quite relatable until it gets a bit more
sci-fi as Hanks suits up and approaches
the breach to investigate it there are
clear references to the film aliens in
not only the creature design but also in
the fact that autocannons are used in a
scene which of course pulls from that
film and Beth appears similar to Vasquez
who was one of the movie's biggest
badasses personally and I may be
reaching with this I also think that
Hanks neighbor Jake looks quite similar
to John Krasinski's character Jim Hobart
from the office Krasinski of course
starred in a quiet place which two
centers around a farm based family
having to deal with an alien
Jake's math is also named carnico which
itself may be a reference to the first
episode from love death and robots
Sonny's edge in which Sonny's beast is
called carnivore anyway back to the plot
after clearing out the initial breach
the families are alerted to several more
breaches which slowly allows countless
amount of creatures also known as DB's
to storm in with help from neighboring
farms Hank attempts to hold the line
whilst the families that live in the
area retreat to bunkers
there's some amazing action scenes that
feel like they could be part of their
own standalone video game and it's never
been a better reason for why we need a
mech Suter it's pretty clear that the
forces are overwhelmed and whilst hank
orders jake to retreat to the bunkers he
instead storms ahead and after being
heavily battle damaged sacrifices
himself in order to clear the field
whilst this manages to kill the majority
of the creatures a giant one that looks
like it was pulled straight out of
Starship Troopers climbs through the
breach and begins approaching the farm
with help from beth and his ally mal
hank is able to take the beast out and
the group are given a moment of respite
as they reflect on the events it's at
this moment that we get the big twist of
the episode which is when the camera
pans out and we realized that we're not
actually on earth the humans are the
alien invaders and this is impact the
creatures planet it appears that the
humans are actually terraforming the
planet and using it for resources which
would lead me to believe that earth is
probably depleted of its own materials
due to humans mining the planet dry
obviously no one would want to be put in
a position where they are forced to live
on a planet like this so it's pretty
safe to say that humanity must be very
desperate no doubt the inhabitants of
the planet view us as a plague which is
why they seem to be constantly attacking
and swarming the pockets that the humans
inhabit it's a great little twist that
completely caught me off guard and I
kind of think that the producers may be
sort of hinting towards an Iraq war
metaphor but when the West went over to
the Middle East and started taking all
that oil I don't want to get too
political though as it's a really fun
episode and that kind of bogs it down a
bit
overall it's a twist that cements the
episode is one of my favorites from the
run and I definitely recommend that you
check it out if you haven't already
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on suits and if you noticed anything
that I may
if you enjoyed this video then please
like it and make sure you check out my
full breakdown of beyond the aquila rift
which would be linked at the end this is
a channel for people who are never
missing television so if that's the kind
of thing you like you need to subscribe
to definition thanks again for taking
the time to watch this you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]